[Music]
justice Clark free legend for a GameSpot
gave what remains of Edith Finch and
9.10 and this games like a more
narrative linear story during game
derogatory term being walking simulator
for those who like a call them that you
know like in the vein of gone home or
dear Esther things like that fire watch
Michael you played last night I sure did
be in about three hours you said yep so
hit me with it try like in a nutshell
was game because I'm I've been confused
about that so either you play as Edith
Finch and it's no mystery that your
family has died of really strange causes
but you know your job is to figure out
how that happened because if you go to
the pause menu you open up your book you
see your family tree and I didn't know
her name from the title there it is on
her journal yeah [ __ ] so you would open
up her journal and yeah it starts off
her telling you what's going on but when
you open the journal in the menu you see
your family tree and everyone's life
spans and many of them have been cut
short and you don't know that it's at
the DNC house oh yeah / oh my gosh yes
Saburo [ __ ] flying car coming in it's
not it's not that so it's not like an
away alright yeah well you go through
their house and their house is basically
a like that's what drives all the
narrative so you visit each of their
rooms and you kind of you look through
their room you read their journal
entries you look through photos and then
it'll take you to a separate gameplay
element where you kind of play what play
themselves the person who died and
through that you find out what happened
to them
and there's some other average things
you're unraveling it's like it's mostly
environmental storytelling is it is it
in the vein of gone gone home one of my
favorite games of the past decade
probably and I it's really important to
me is it is it kind of in that similar
yeah you get some get some high key gone
home vibes from it when you say strange
you mean they are strange or like
atmospherically or
you know magic strange strange as in um
doesn't the aesthetic of the house
changed throughout like someone was
saying there's a huge variety of
environments even though you're in like
a house the whole time when you when you
go into each person's kind of life story
that's when the house changes because
you can almost gotcha
time travel through what happened to
them at their last moments okay so that
that's kind of what the trend going back
to what you asked like there's it's not
very supernatural like but strange as in
there's it's a combination of things
some suffer from what I think is some
sort of mental illness some suffer from
just boredom or some are just died
through accidents and it's for you to
kind of unravel the like the more
mysterious ones are very esoteric and
you almost have to like make up your own
mind about what I mean hurry though dad
did you read that that was my I do not
my grandma's been seven years sharing a
bedroom with her dead brother yup like
that before we whoa my brothers he's
dying but he's in my room
I didn't yeah before we move on to your
you're like critiques of it because I
want to get you now that you played
through it I know you haven't had a lot
of time for just do like I said Justin
Clark reviews up on GameSpot but I do
have a question from Twitter
apologies for pulling on my phone to
this which you can't even see right now
but John Christian Jenson asks which
family members story and what remains
was your favorite made the biggest
impact he talked about that without
spoilers like uh or like what is there
like one totally that yeah he like there
there's one that stood out very clear to
me Wow
for like personal reasons or is it like
a horror thing I heard there's some
horror elements this game there are some
horror elements but there's nothing like
Resident Evil 7 but in terms of the one
that stood out to me I forgot his name
cuz I just played yesterday but it's
towards the end when you get to the top
of the house it has how I not spoil this
though you play as him he's like in the
he works in the cannery so he's like
cutting up fish for his job naturally
but his mind travels elsewhere
throughout his job because he has a
mundane job I mean I was like a really
wild imagination because Secret Life of
Walter Mitty
sure my bad not no that's fine don't
spoil it you're good but then it's what
I really like about it yeah Wow it's a
grandmother thing John Luke accidentally
pulled up Eagle flight footage get back
to you - Finch thank you John Boop no
this is just part of it oh that's all I
eat that [ __ ] yeah they're good get in
there
guys you hungry now this United oh it
speaking of mama Oh dad everything was
going to say this is everything okay
this part actually made me laugh really
hard that shut up as it you're a normal
human being with it's so cute it's like
with half a brain this should pick you
laughs it's so cute though um I mean
really weird stuff and it's a
combination of moments like this where
you're happy and laughing and it's silly
but then you're hit okay so definitely
okay I'm done I'm gonna interject here
so something we talked about with
everything a while back was like the
comedy didn't always mix with the more
like introspective stuff it sounds like
with Finch it meshes better or the the
tonal shifts didn't jar you as much
right like it from what you're saying it
sounds like they mesh well together well
I can't get over this shark yeah this is
one of the more strange I keep saying
that word but it's really weird yeah
they've dead but each sequence makes you
do a different gameplay thing so it's
not like you're turned into an animal
all the time right like those those
ships front like this sort of saying
versus my grandma slept next to her dead
brother or whatever like that doesn't
that jarring at all
I mean I I kind of expected this to be
out there in the ether might actually
you know it's just a rope dude I like it
technology that's a snake man shut up
it's hard to talk about without spilling
the beans because part of the enjoyment
is discovering what am I going to turn
into when I unravel this person's story
or hit this like my uncle who did this
so each each sequence is very different
it tells a different story but it all
ends up very sad
even though even the happy moments
result in death like that's not it
everybody's dead yeah all y'all is dead
so so it's a mystery that they are dead
it's just how they died and what they
left for the family is what you'd want
to uncover and yeah I was going to say
something about how I felt about how the
ending kind of brings everything
together but I gonna say that cuz I mean
in terms of pacing did you ever get
bored during this I mean it's three
hours long but did it kind of earn all
those minutes it did yeah there was
never a part where it's like oh my god I
gotta get through this part this is like
so boring um there there's once one
critique I do have of it is that some of
the parts like the movement itself is
very slow and it's kind of like what am
I going to go go to this end of the room
did you remember everybody's gone to the
rapture game of that review initially
thank game reminding me of that it's
very much like that all the heavy text
kind of like I don't know that like
bloom I remember uh Marty's Leela from
IGN did not know that you could run in
that game and so a lot of it well yeah
like it was like a mystery run button
yeah yeah that's what I thought up too
cuz they know sprinting in this one but
I mean it's fine I think yeah sometimes
it works to its advantage because I want
to stop in the rooms and look at the
books that are there the photos the
write the scribble notes stop on all the
photos it's exactly yeah it's all
looking a lot of environmental
storytelling in addition to like
sometimes I feel like words coming up on
the screen can be heavy-handed like
especially when it's like yeah that's
one thing I appreciate about this game
it's not it's not heavy-handed it
doesn't like tell you everything like oh
this person died because of this it's
more like this is what happened it's up
to you to decide what that means to you
so the overt narration the written text
doesn't get in the way I mean the reason
I love going homes because they didn't
have any of that if you didn't want to
pick something up and read it it's not
it's not text heavy though like you'll
you'll see on-screen Edith will think to
itself and that will be displayed in
text on the screen but it's usually like
a sentence or two I mean it's not like
she goes into this exposition and
monologue Chlo yeah the pacing is açaí
cool ah good three hours
yeah tough game check talk about without
spoiling but if you all watching on
twitch or YouTube want to go check out
our review Justin Clark a freelance for
GameSpot has about
gamespot now give it a 9 out of 10 it's
getting good scores across the board so
and it's like three hours would you play
on PC PC yep you can go check that out
today if you want that is out and we'll
be able to maybe talk about it more if
if you have got a chance to play let me
know in the chat and we can just don't
spell anything cuz I won't play it
[Music]